[Music]
in partner versus pride news submitted
by JK rewind that female hunter has
received death threats for posting
pictures of her kills to Instagram I
thought this was kind of annoying yeah
like yeah cuz she's doing like big big
game hunting right yeah what's going on
what's the controversy here I just check
it off lions and giraffes yeah no so she
okay so this check her name is Kate
small she kills hogs deer wolves and
bears and her hometown of Boise Idaho
and she also visits South Africa and
stuff to do hunting trips as well so she
post photos of her kills but she does
say that she like rather or except for
wolves yeah doesn't let her kill go to
waste
like she why did she kill the wolves
though cuz you not supposed to do that
because it ruins the ecosystems who says
she says she's very mindful of so she's
very mindful of hunting in an ethical
way which means she only kills her
animals for food or for conservation so
what's the wolves about I don't know she
hates holes I said she hates wolves they
have parasites that could get you sick
or something so losin eat it could be a
population see the beers I've never
heard nobody always wonder why we don't
eat bears I they like boy bears they do
yeah I my friends a dad is a hunter and
he hunts bears and another like a lot he
hunts everything they eat sever eating
that he can't hurt and he says that
bears are very gamey because I was
always like I thought you weren't
supposed to hunt predators but yes she
says she wants a peck yeah animals so
they don't eat Lions billary lions and
tigers panthers I met you back in a day
people ate whatever the hell they could
yeah probably
maybe it tastes good controversy because
it's like you're not eating them it's
just a trophy kill instead of like well
that's like in the frontier you ain't
bears because they're around and yeah
you attack me they attack you or you go
hunt them or whatever use them for them
yeah now it seems weird cuz you can go
to the grocery store yeah
oh yeah I'm cool with the hunting prey
right but yeah whenever I see predators
killed it always weirds me out a little
bit what if he eating it I would like to
eat all of them is Kate so she says
she's received thousands and thousands
of love death threats oh it's not love
no they're not like thank you Kay for
killing these animals because they were
so for pooping everywhere they were
going around and biting people thank you
for cleaning up the streets with all the
dangerous predators okay the next one oh
that's [ __ ] sad like look at that
little cub cuz it's a mammal so if she
did that what a big [ __ ] ugly tuna
yeah our people still trigger oh good
this is my question
tunas gonna get eaten she's not gonna
eat that wolf the same people that would
send her these Deafness first of all
just think that's ridiculous tip let me
kill somebody because they killed animal
like that's just ridiculous but would
you would they be just as upset if these
animals were killed by other animals
violence too like that a quick death
maybe saying they're just not be some of
the worship everything sitting there as
lion jizz get 8 she said a hunting helps
these animals combat spread of disease
and competition for food I know people
think hunting is cruel but it isn't you
know what squirrel mother nature have
you ever seen an elk get half eaten by
wolves and suffer for hours while it
slowly and painfully dies have you ever
seen a mule deer gradually waste away
and eventually die of starvation I don't
know about you but to me a single shot
to the vital sounds like a much better
way to go music I see all this [ __ ] I
jerk off but its nature just being
nature we shouldn't intervene aren't we
made to be forgetting that we made to
turn no that's what I mean that we
should be shooting people because they
might die of a hurricane
yes said we should all be harsh because
it's more it's nicer I believe them
that's my next campaign let's shoot
people I just want
died of a hurricane I wish that this
chick could just be honest and be like
listen I kill animals cuz I like it like
it it gets me off a little
the justification it's all a morality
issue it's always like these I would
have been like [ __ ] you I got a good and
imma shoot up yeah it's always counter
preachy lecturing it's cuz it's not
illegal that's if it's not illegal then
how are you even getting definite about
it it's also so twisted to because she's
saying that she's gotten death threats
uh saying I'm going to put your baby
because she has a one-year-old daughter
I'm gonna put your baby in a blender and
listen to her scream yeah another one
baby did do anything no but another one
said that she I can't believe you
[ __ ] catch trout you [ __ ] I'm gonna
kill your baby
another one said that people are going
to murder her dogs so she was like how
the [ __ ] are you
animal because you're angry that I'm
killing a man that's the thing that I
never understood like that just that to
even put that in your mind to talk about
putting a baby in a blood like you're
crazy to [ __ ] you just talking about
most of those crazy people just that's
psychotic is something like that but
look at that chick wall she's smiling
whole now wolf dude I'm like Jesus you
got a smile like this holding off
[ __ ] dead wall it's pretty weird
right I just think that she should be
honest about his own this oh yeah who
you are so I don't kill people but
that's but I think we're the weird ones
in the city we're the ones in the city
because we're so disconnected to death
and nature and this is just normal and I
don't this I guess what I understand
about it like what if what if somebody
has a farm and you have a farm you got
chickens are you gonna give me death
that thing because I'm killing these
chickens yeah you seem like you know
animal rights activists like like
documentaries I feel like look at them
killing these cows I'm like yeah maybe
do it too much as sometimes a backfire
there's a video they went to like go
never to go protest so they went in like
they're like that conveyor belt they're
like so they like lock themselves and it
so if you go protest Cupido but Joey
follow through no I want to be the one
so yeah so here's a
quote she said I like being able to know
exactly where my food came from and not
only that but working extremely hard to
get it I like being able to provide
organic nutritious meals from my family
this lifestyle also lets me create
everlasting memories with my friends and
my family even if I'm unable to harvest
an animal memories made on a mountain
battling the elements and being pushed
to your limit are invaluable it's a true
test of your inner strength and
character I salvaged as much of the
animal as I possibly can I always keep
the head and hide for mounting the meat
is what we live off of we butcher it
ourselves and then we will eat it for
the rest of the year spiritual with
their [ __ ] way what type of meat are
they giving us our lasts for the rest of
the year well I don't know there's a lot
of [ __ ] me but if they have big
frigerators I see that it's the one
where she's like even if I can't harvest
the animal I'm still gonna kill it cuz
the memories Yeah right my pro hunting
but I'm like man this [ __ ] takes delight
I never take an animal for fun it's for
food or for conservation well then why
are you smiling then like smiling
ear-to-ear I caught it she can still
have fun while she's doing it though
right like would you rather have Steve
she's like said taking the picture is
like I look what I did you know that's
cuz she's trying to like get this hobby
for more women to be involved because
she's saying man I know this chick that
we were we're at a wedding and this
chick was super good at hunting deer
like is she she does the whole thing and
like she skins and like does the stuff
that I couldn't do like if I was a
hunter oozing deer she doesn't tell
anybody about LSD unless they ask about
it but when I do when she told me about
it I poured red wine on her
did you throw and
I cut up a chicken like one time I was
trying it the chickens are cute a
chicken like full apart I mean it was
ready like I didn't kill her one side or
anything but it was just from the
grocery store but like a whole chicken
I'm like trying to cut through the
breast that's how disconnected we are to
actual nature I always thought about
like how butchers or stuff do that like
they have to like really be blood and
I'll be like yep you get used to it I
don't know that I could stomach better
I just feel the death of it is weird but
definitely yeah don't eat vegetables
you're eating life when you eat animals
you're eating death think about that
miles
ESCA Tyrion when I eat a [ __ ] spake
that was smoked but the plant it didn't
die I'm eating it alive no it's nice
it's only dead if it's dying I'm killing
it alive making the life out of do when
you look into the unit when you look
into the universe all you see is [ __ ]
death and chaos and [ __ ] one galaxy
absorbing another galaxy through
destruction like come on man and we got
pretty sick here actually I like the
little peaceful galaxy the one where
everyone's like I think what this speaks
more to though is that people always
feel like they want to control other
people if this is what this lady does
exactly she is not breaking the law you
don't have the right to be like on the
kilian difference in culture to because
I bet you it's a lot of city people
that's never seen hunting never really
goes into nature they don't understand
this [ __ ] at all so they see it and
they're like oh my god I killed the Dyer
rose and Game of Thrones you're saying
that's totally fine no never nobody
cried about that okay
I was just thinking about Ben's watching
and catching up it happens in Episode
one Oh
okay been watching we're starting I
think I think people don't look at it
scientifically either because a lot of
the these animals are invasive species
like hogs and there's way too much deer
they're over pop words like have you
seen the overall population of [ __ ]
horses in Nevada like oh just [ __ ]
starve they like start eating each other
and [ __ ] everybody had to reintroduce
the wolf population and because they
can't we killed off so many wolves yeah
they're dropping wolf yeah okay
population control yeah exactly they
threw off the whole ecosystem there I
just found this out this might make me
sound stupid and that's okay cuz y'all
know that dogs are the senders of wolves
mm-hmm I just run as always like
yesterday years old I was praying for
something but then I you did say oh wait
you couldn't tell by the pause or the
pointy ears or the snout I just never
got me this dogs or dogs it was the
world it was like how did you find out
no matter of a key like you know the
descendants of well what did you say I
want to thank you because I'm not a
smart man but you just made me feel
really smart dogs and foxes are in the
same family too
dogs and foxes but they don't both come
from wolves though no so they're like
stepchildren involved here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]